- So, you just turned 50,
and you had a surprise
birthday party, right?
How did it go?
- Yes. It was a surprise.
My sons took me out,
which I was hoping I wouldn't
have to pick up the bill.
But it worked that really well,
but I learned something since I'm 50.
So, I wish people would realize
that I'm a plus size woman.
When I park, I need a sign say "I'm fat,"
and they park too close to my door.
- [Kelly] Oh, you can't get in your car?
- Yeah. So, last week I had to go,
and I had on these little
liquid pants, like young girls.
And so, I couldn't get in my car,
I had to take 'em off.
'Cause I couldn't spread my legs
that wide to get over the console.
- Oh, you came through the passenger.
- Yes. But I'm out there
with not matching underwear,
and I'm driving, and I'm like, "oh Lord,
if the police pull me over,
then he gonna think I'm
naked from the front."
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- And I'm driving down,
40 miles, going home,
and I'm just sticking to the seat,
and I'm sweating.
Then I'm call my man,
"I'm in my underwear."
He was like, "why?"
I was like, "it's a long story."
And I was like, I'm just
gonna put a sign of my car.
I'm fat. Be courteous.
And give me room to get in my car.
- Be courteous. Not fat, just thicker.
That's all. That's all.
But wait, Ice Cube sent
you a birthday message.
- Oh, my God.
Girl, if I had on the Spanx
that day, I would've died.
- Wait, so wait, I wanna see this.
I wanna show everyone real quick.
Let's see. Let's see.
- Happy birthday, Ms. Pat
from your homie Ice Cube.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I see you out there, girl.
- That is so cool.
He's so nice.
I met him once. He's so nice.
- I've never met him, but I've always
dreamed of working with Ice Cube.
Two people I wanna meet,
Whitney Houston, and Ice Cube,
and Whitney checked out too.
- Okay. I was like, that's gonna tough.
- It's gonna be tough,
unless I meet the hologram.
But...
I forget this daytime TV.
Catch up ya'll, catch up.
So, I always wanted to
work and meet Ice Cube,
I worked for V103 in Atlanta, Georgia,
with a big ticket morning show,
and they know how much I love Ice Cube.
He called in and I, my
wigs fell off that morning.
So, my husband called
right after Ice Cube,
I was like, "who is this? Do I know you?"
- Who this, wrong number?
- Well, I was like, "baby,
Ice Cube just called me,
can you call me back tomorrow?
- So, wait, you're so funny,
and I wanna talk about
your new special show.
Your special on Netflix,
it's called, Y'all Wanna
Hear Something Crazy,
which I love the title of that.
So, Wanda Sykes, I heard
she produced it, right?
- Wanda Sykes produced it.
- I love females promoting females.
This is awesome.
- When I got the deal from
Netflix, I immediately said,
I want Wanda Sykes to produce it.
And then after Wanda Sykes,
we brought on Robert Townsend,
and they was like, "oh, we don't know
if Robert Townsend will do it."
I'm like Robert Townsend?
Oh, look at it.
I was like, he's gonna do it.
I'm gonna pray.
And we worked out some things
and Robert Townsend did it,
but I gotta tell you,
when you ask Robert
Townsend to do your special,
you better be serious about comedy.
'Cause he made me practice
for four hours a week,
four hours for one day.
And I had to send him all
of my recordings on Zoom,
which I thought it was
the craziest thing I ever had ever done.
- Is it 'cause he wanted
to know how to capture,
like the joke and like, and make sure...
- He wanted to make sure
you was delivering it right.
He wanted make sure it was no fat on it.
He was cutting stuff.
He was helping me put stuff together.
And I was like, "this is stupid."
That's what I said.
But I dreaded,
I said, "oh I gotta go
talk to Robert Townsend."
But when it came out I
was like, "oh my God,
I'm so glad I listened to him."
- Oh, that's so awesome.
That's a good experience.
- Thank you, Robert. Thank you.
- Well we need a break.
Ms. Pat's special,
Y'all Wanna Hear Something Crazy,
is streaming right now, on Netflix.
And make sure to watch the
Ms. Pat show on BET and BET+.